I've reported before on Donald Trump's
worst days of his presidency and there
have been some pretty bad days for
Donald Trump yesterday might have been
Donald Trump's best day ever and I don't
actually mean that because I believe
that Robert Moeller's report truly
exonerates Trump in fact it says that it
cannot exonerate Trump from obstruction
of justice but as a result of this vague
politicized summary from Donald Trump's
hand-picked attorney general right-wing
media went bonkers for 24 straight hours
declaring Trump cleared of any
wrongdoing completely vindicated even
though it's not even his Attorney
General's call to make that decision on
the matter of obstruction as I've
already told you it doesn't matter
though the storyline is coherent the
storyline is compelling Trump has
successfully framed himself as the
victim and it's working in that there is
now a 48 hours of right-wing media going
bonkers titillated and aroused by the
idea that Donald Trump has indeed been
cleared so that's really good for Trump
already and then in addition to that one
of Donald Trump's political opponents
one of those pesky political opponents
of Donald Trump attorney Michael
avenatti who represented Donald Trump's
silenced mitts mistress stormy Daniels
has been arrested yet again and this
time it is federal charges in two cases
one in California one in New York this
includes most notably an attempt to
extort Nike for 20 million dollars
threatening to release damaging
information about Nike if they didn't
pay him separately chart there were also
charges against avenatti for bank and
wire fraud for allegedly embezzling
money from a client and filing fake tax
returns with the bank as the story is
currently being reported avenatti was
all set to have a press conference
disclosing some scandal involving Nike
and instead he gets arrested for trying
to extort them into paying him to cancel
that press conference this is
extraordinarily embarrassing
hypothetically from all of this stuff
together avenatti could potentially face
50
years in prison unlikely but the details
are stunning and it's sort of exactly
what we would expect from a shady lawyer
whose priority all along has been to do
what's best for him to do what a grand
eise's him the most and when you and I
talked about this before Pat when there
were rumblings about could avenatti
maybe be the 2020 Democratic nominee I
don't think you thought it was a good
idea I didn't think it was a good idea
and I think at this point all talk of
that has to be dead I think so
especially it's gonna be hard for him to
run a successful presidential campaign
when he's in prison yeah I mean no no uh
no hard feelings about this I'm not
gonna lose any sleep that Michael
avenatti is going to be sent to prison
we'll see what goes on out melee with
that case and just really good for Trump
I mean the timing coming on the same day
as Trump's I'm vindicated sort of right
wing media echo chamber and Trump's ego
is now reinforced Trump's audacity is
going to expand and like I said
yesterday Donald Trump is quickly
barreling towards a big-time reelection
if nothing changes now I do want to say
one other thing about the avenatti
component to this as far as Nike goes I
don't know the full details of what was
even alleged by Michael avenatti that
Nike was doing wrong it's very possible
that Nike is involved in some insanely
shady stuff which may or may not have to
do with the college admissions scandal I
read one suggestion that that's maybe
what it was connected to these are just
rumors at this point in time that's all
they are just rumors I hope that
ultimately if there is something to
learn about what Nike is doing that we
learn about it avenatti is a shady
character he shouldn't run for president
we'll see if he ends up spending time in
prison as a result of all this there's
no question about that but it's totally
plausible that avenatti did uncover some
kind of shady or possibly corrupt or
even criminal behavior on behalf of Nike
it's just a huge corporation that is not
immoral but amoral and these
corporations very often engage in
behavior that can be criminal or at
minimum unethical and if that's the case
I want to know about it whether we hear
about it from Michael avenatti or
someone else
threatening them with a pay me or I will
go clean come clean with this go public
with it it's not the right way to go
about it but if indeed Nike has been
involved in shady stuff again and I say
again because you go back 10 15 years
you know Nike has been involved and all
sorts of shady stuff I do hope
ultimately we learn what it is and I
don't it's an I think it's important for
us not to ignore the fact that there may
actually be serious allegations here
related to Nike and if there are I hope
we at some point hear about them not
from someone saying give me 20 million
or 2 million or whatever it was a Vinod
he wanted here today's program was made
possible in part by a simple habit an
app for iOS Android and web browser that
gives you access to more than 2,000
guided meditations you can try it free
for one week by going to simple habit
comm slash Pakman simple habit has
meditations made specifically for
anxiety falling asleep overcoming
procrastination getting focused there's
a meditation for almost anything you are
dealing with in life and there is
constantly new scientific research
emerging about the benefits of
meditating regarding your physical
health your mental well-being your
social life your cognitive performance
it's a long list
I personally make meditation part of my
day I've been doing it for a while and
simple habit makes it incredibly easy to
stick to a meditation routine each
guided meditation is just five minutes
long they have meditations specifically
designed for waking up for your daily
commute when you get home from work
every part of your day the massive
variety of different kinds of
meditations that simple habit offers is
what really sets the app apart and they
just won the 2018 Google Play award for
best well-being app you can try it
completely free for a week by going to
simple habit calm slash Pakman I think
you'll love it I've put a link right
underneath this video